meanwhile dr seuss is not the only only
cartoonist under fire
the cat in the hat is not the only
victim of cancel culture
pepe le pew pep you're you know pepe le
pew he's that sort of girl crazy snake
or a skunk rather from from the old
cartoons pepe le pew
is uh being accused of perpetuating rape
culture according to charles blow at the
new york times
which is on the same tier of journalism
as the washington post
charles blow writes some of the first
cartoons i can remember included pepe le
pew
who normalized rape culture blo then
followed this up he said
right wing blogs are mad because i said
pepe le pew added to rape culture
let's see one he grabs kisses a girl
stranger repeatedly
without consenting against her will she
struggles mightily to get away from him
but he won't release her three he locks
a door
to prevent her from escaping boom there
it is lock him up
lock up that skunk pepe le pew he did it
seems to me no one has ever committed
rape
because a cartoon skunk told them that
it was okay
i'm willing to go out on a limb and say
that
but i actually don't think that that is
why they want to cancel pepe le pew
or any sort of old cartoons that in any
way
contradict the ever-changing dictates of
political correctness
i think it's something deeper than that
i think it's because
one the the left has a point when they
talk about anti-racist babies they
actually do have a point
our brains are forming when we're very
little that's why we educate children
more than we educate adults because you
can shape those brains so so sure that
that matters also because
these cartoons subtly are questioning
the premises of political correctness
it's exaggerated and sort of ridiculous
with pepe le pew
but what is what is being exaggerated
what's being exaggerated is that men
find women attractive that men and women
are different
they are complementary men pursue women
in a way that women do not pursue men
because men and women relate
to sex and romance differently
that's the problem that's what the left
doesn't like
that's what is a threat to the left-wing
agenda not because anyone thinks a skunk
is getting people to commit rape
what's offensive in those dr seuss books
well the doctors books are saying
different cultures are different
they have different customs different
traditions it's not all just the same
bland secular liberalism
that's the threat that's the big threat
here
and these are you don't need to defend
uh uh
pepe lapu's rape culture to say wait a
second here guys
we need to keep these old cartoons these
old jokes this old
fun because one the these
these jokes this levity this artwork
embellishes life makes it much more
interesting but also because
there are there are some premises in
here and they're deeper and they're
basic and they're absolutely just and
they're absolutely
defensible but our elites
they do not want to do that i don't even
know if they can muster the argument for
that
is there any is there any uh question
why people are losing faith in their
institutions and their rituals and their
system of government
i don't think it's the people's fault i
think it's the fault
of this desiccated shallow elite
that refuses to take on any sort of
responsibility to the people and when
the elite are not responsive to the
people we hear about this
in the federalist papers then society
starts to
break down if you enjoyed that break
from disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you